kim and khloe kardashian are bringing
the heat to miami that's kim and khloe
kardashian taking over miami with their
daring looks to celebrate the launch of
skim's new swimwear line the famous
sisters visited the pop-up shop over the
weekend and made sure to bring the glam
we all want to be cute over here okay
check out kim's sexy metallic bikini top
with matching leggings and chunky
sunglasses
little sister chloe goes with a blue
dress with sheer cut out panels and
matching blue shades the 41 year old
beauty mogul and 37 year old good
american co-founder made time for dinner
with friends at miami restaurant swan to
celebrate the collection i am honestly i
put my heart and soul into skims that
was kim in 2019 shortly after she
launched her shapewear line she told et
at the time it was a brand born out of
necessity i have spent so many years
cutting up shapewear sewing shapewear
dyeing shapewear
with our tape you know using every kind
of tape you can imagine gaffers tape
shipping tape not only did kim manifest
her dream business but she may also have
her dream guy the kim one isn't a tattoo
it's actually a branding yep that was
kim on ellen last week just days after
going instagram official with her
boyfriend pete davidson i have the
cutest pictures of us and i want to be
like oh my god we're so cute and i want
you know but then i'm like
you know
don't be so desperate don't be posting
so much just give a glimpse
of course the pair started dating in
october after kim hosted snl now are you
gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and while kim told variety earlier this
month that pete was not filmed for the
family's new hulu reality series she did
confirm that she'll be dishing all about
her new romance
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming from who are
you texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
so while kim's relationship is thriving
chloe seems to be in a different phase
of life after splitting from her ex
tristan thompson who admitted earlier
this year that he fathered a child with
marlene nichols tristan and i are
complicated
trust takes time
naturally close sisters kim and courtney
can't help but be there for their
sibling in fact a source told e.t
earlier this month that they're actually
trying to set their younger sister up
with one of pete or travis barker's pals
as for how coco feels about it our
source explains quote chloe wants it to
be organic and not have her whole family
know a play-by-play plus coco seems to
be doing fine on her own i just want to
live my life and be happy she was
hanging out with trey songz last
saturday in los angeles at a party
thrown by justin bieber e.t source
reveals they were sitting in a booth
talking one-on-one but it appeared to be
mostly friendly the source also shares
that the reality star and r b singer
quote left the party at around the same
time
ultimately we're told chloe is happy by
herself and will start dating when she's
ready for now she's focusing on being
mom to her three-year-old daughter true
thompson
[Music]